so we all love jokes and here at the
show we've been talking a lot about
different jokes I'm not just telling
them we're talking about them
okay listen I think there are some jokes
that are overdone and need to get out of
here like forever so we're doing a bit
called joke retirement alright so here's
a joke that I think needs to go crap it
won't scan oh no must be free oh you
don't know how much it costs I will
wager a guess free is it free give it to
me for free
ah to that joke shut your mouth
the joke is over the cashier every
cashier hears it a thousand times a day
stop it it's not free if you're making
that joke you're free you're worthless
be quiet must be free is retired retired
and I know I know what you're thinking
but Pete what am I supposed to say next
time I'm at the store and something
won't scan I have an idea anything else
literally anything would be better than
must be free for example crap it won't
scan my why
I know it doesn't make sense we release
it's funny